[Music]  gimana who sylveon was based on came to  America to go to a two-year silent  retreat it started to feel like this  metaphor for the whole experience of  coming to America like the weirdness of  a silent retreat and that you're looking  to pick up on human behaviors now look  around at people's fear in a way the  silence in the episode was almost like  the great equalizer because once you  took away language no one knew she was a  foreigner  because the episode was in silence you  needed visual ways to explore what was  happening in her brain I decided that  Silvia was going to have these weird  hallucinations  [Music]  this episode explores the ways were all  different and how that can prevent  connection sometimes but I think the  cool thing about this episode is it  shows much more about how we're all  alike than  [Music]  you  you